group included groundbreaking Asian
Americans like Vera Wang and and and
Joan Shin Gangnam Style
koala I think I pronounced it correctly
the Reuben report I'm Dave Rubin I think
I pronounced that correctly it's May 16
2023 we're live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals share subscribe tap
that notification Bell if you have not
if you want to join us for the post game
show which we do every day after the
show
reubenreport.locals.com and I have to
say this is day two being back in studio
after our international trip yesterday I
was kind of shaking off some of the rust
I realized at the end of the show that I
wasn't particularly funny yesterday and
I know it's very important that you
people tune into the news and laugh
about it because everyone's completely
bananas and today I will be easing into
more comedy and the old Dave that you've
come to low uh know and love that's what
we will be getting to today the theme of
the show because you know I did this
international trip
and I was really trying to focus on
culture what is right in some other
places and contrast that with what is
wrong in America right now and we have a
lot wrong with our culture whether it's
family whether it's what's coming from
our media and our educational
institutions and not knowing what's true
or false or boys or girls or any of
those things also this obsession with
race that we have so uh Phoenix found
this clip yesterday it's from about a
year or so ago of Oprah Winfrey now you
remember Oprah she had a big talk show
for a couple decades in America she
often is now seen eating bread in a
forest with some of her friends but
somehow not gaining weight remember that
commercial that was the thing she was
always in a forest at a very nice table
she would find this very fancy dining
table with a chandelier in the forest
she'd eat bread with a bunch of other
women who frankly look a little
overweight but somehow they were never
gaining weight anyway she's also been in
some movies and done some other things
um we found this video of her uh
commenting on fatherhood in the the
black community and I thought it would
be a nice way to frame the show today
because so much of what's going on here
we always are arguing about politics but
it's not really about politics right
it's about it's about our cultural norms
our what's going on with all of us
spiritually our families our
relationships with each other and then
politics is just a reflection of all of
that screwiness so I want to talk about
sort of fatherhood the importance of men
in society and how that's related to why
we end up not knowing if boys or girls
and we have open borders and all sorts
of stuff so we're going to talk about
nationalism we're going to talk about
strong men and a whole bunch more I'm
feeling quite strong today I had my
coffee I ate a little toast to this
morning and before we get to all of that
let me talk to you about Phoenix Capital
you know with banks collapsing and the
turbulent state of the stock market
millions of Americans have watched their
retirement savings disappear I want to
share with you a unique investment
opportunity that's not only protecting
retirement savings but investors are
seeing consistent yields and growth
Phoenix Capital group is offering
high-value U.S oil and gas Investments
through their corporate bonds it's a way
for people to invest in energy assets
and diversify their portfolio yields
range from 8 to 12 percent apy paid
monthly with different qualifications
and maturity dates Phoenix Capital group
is a tech-led Energy company owning in
some of the most lucrative basins Across
America investor Capital along with
their own Capital goes towards cash flow
positive oil and gas projects they had
the choice of offering a significantly
lower interest rate and paying the
difference to middlemen but decided to
break the mold and bring stronger
Investments directly to investors these
eight to twelve percent apy corporate
bonds are higher than CDs or annuities
often more than double the typical yield
so if you're looking for an alternative
investment with sizable sizable yields
and monthly payment options I highly
recommend checking out Phoenix Capital
groups Bond offering rings to learn more
download their free investor guide at
phxon reuben.com let them know you heard
it from me and now back to me all right
so let's start with Oprah Winfrey Oprah
Winfrey as you know big talk show host
been in a lot of movies cultural Force
started a TV network does the TV network
still exist The Zone still exists nobody
knows doesn't matter anyway you know
Oprah uh here is Oprah about a year and
a half ago commenting on black
fatherhood and uh well it's a little bit
different than some of the things you
might be hearing about from some of the
people I often talk about on the show
say Larry Elder Thomas Soul et cetera
Etc take a look
there's been this Landmark study from
the Center for Disease Control which
debunked many of the myths surrounding
black father as it found the majority of
black fathers live with their children
black fathers are more likely to help
their children with their homework
prepare meals bathe and dress their
children compared to fathers of other
races so the absent or deadbeat black
father myth that many in America believe
is really more like a lie
okay so we're going to get into some of
her confusions in just a moment and some
of the guys that I talked about Larry
Elder Thomas for example we're gonna
we're gonna get you numbers on that the
reason I wanted to play this clip and I
don't really even mean to make this
about black people specifically there
are some obvious things that we all know
if you have two parents in a house if in
that household there are strong Role
Models there are people who have a
certain degree of responsibility and try
to raise those kids fairly we know this
leads to success so why she's trying to
diminish that is a little bit confusing
she's also confused about the stats and
again I'll get to the stats in just a
second
um Oprah should want everybody
regardless of color it shouldn't it
shouldn't be Pro anyway it shouldn't be
in anyone's uh wheelhouse a certain
Pride that their race has more people in
the home or anything else we should want
that for absolutely everybody so let's
uh let's jump and get to some numbers
here this is from the Federalist as the
nation emerged from Jim Pro 25 percent
of black children were born to unwed
mothers today that statistic is 72
percent so Oprah is confused about her
stats they're 72 percent of black
children are born to unwed mothers
instances of racism exist today
obviously but you will be hard-pressed
to argue anti-black racism is worse now
than in 1900 or 1964. so it's not just
that Oprah's bizarre claim is completely
inaccurate but it's also damaging to the
black community and to the nation at
large for the reasons that my friend
Larry Elder laid out right here in one
of his pragaryu videos
as between the presence of white racism
and the absence of black fathers I asked
him which poses the bigger threat to the
black community
without missing a beat he said the
absence of black fathers it was
President Barack Obama who said we all
know these statistics that children who
grow up without a father are five times
more likely to live in poverty and
commit crime nine times more likely to
drop out of school and 20 times more
likely to end up in prison
the Journal of research on adolescence
confirms that even after controlling for
varying levels of household income kids
and farther absent homes are more likely
to end up in jail and kids who never had
a father in the house are the most
likely to wind up behind bars okay so
again let's let's remove the race
element for just a second and talk about
the the last part of what Larry's saying
right there if fathers are not in the
home if you don't have two parents in
the home you rapidly and exponentially
increase the chance that that kid is
going to get involved in drugs and crime
and a whole bunch of other stuff and
then when you do that for Generations
what starts happening is the cultural
rot that we have now right that's that
sort of works its way up into everything
and then you have people who are angry
because a certain set of people just go
ahead and have a couple parents and some
kids and try to live a decent life and
they're thought of as turfs or other
scary names Thomas Soul even well before
Larry Elder has been talking about this
for decades that the problem within the
black community let's say is not about
race it's not about racism against them
it's actually about fatherlessness and
you'll find it interesting when that all
began take a look
uh you find that married couple families
were much more prevalent among blacks
then than today most black kids grew up
in homes with two parents under slavery
itself and for Generations thereafter
and as late as the 1960s most black
children grew up in two parent homes
when you think about it I mean uh
centuries of slavery
generations of Jim Crow did not destroy
the black family
but one one generation of the welfare
state
ah okay so that's the part that I want
to Now link to the rest of the show that
throughout slavery throughout Jim Crow
decades Generations as he's saying there
were still more two-parent black homes
than white homes right it wasn't until
the welfare state so now we're talking
about the early 1970s when basically the
Democrats came in and they came in with
affirmative action and they came in with
all these handouts that suddenly the
black community started to break down in
the home this is just a fact there's
nothing racist about talking uh racist
by talking about that right but now we
are seeing the results of those policies
Generations later we're going to get to
that in just a second let me talk to you
about Birch gold group real quick uh you
know president Trump recently issued a
warning from his Mar-A-Lago home quote
our currency is crashing and will soon
no longer be the world standard which
will be our greatest defeat in frankly
200 years there are three reasons the
central banks are dumping the U.S dollar
inflation deficit spending and our
insurmountable national debt the fact is
there's one asset that has withstood
famine Wars and political and economic
upheaval dating back to Biblical times
yeah that's gold and you can own it in a
tax sheltered retirement account with
the help of Birch gold that's right
Birch gold will help you convert an
existing Ira or 401K maybe from a
previous employer into an IRA in gold
and the best part you don't pay a penny
out of pocket just visit birchgold.com
Dave today for your free info kit
they'll hold your hand through the whole
process think about this when currencies
fail gold is a safe haven how much more
time does the Dollar have protect your
savings with gold like I did Birch gold
has an A plus rating With Better
Business Bureau and thousands of happy
customers visit birchgold.com Dave to
get your free info kit on gold
birchgold.com David now back to me okay
so
our whole country
everybody guys just black people need to
realize that there is a crisis here
right there is a crisis in the family
there is a crisis in fatherhood there's
a crisis in manhood but with that said
why is it that black Americans are
suddenly opposing things like illegal
immigration because it hurts their
communities even more because their
communities are already banged up as is
because of the welfare state that Thomas
soul is talking about so the reason I
did all of that at the front was to get
you to this part because for the last
two weeks or so in America we have been
dealing with the impending end of title
42 and this absolute onslaught of our
borders right and what's happening the
federal government is just letting tens
of thousands of people they are not
the tired and the poor and the huddled
masses these are people who just want to
get into America right and often they're
bringing drugs and crime and a whole
bunch more they are rampaging through
the Border towns in Texas they are going
to Sanctuary cities fortunately I live
in a place called The Free State of
Florida and we are shipping them out
when they get here uh but what is
happening they are going to these
Sanctuary cities like Chicago where
already they have a huge problem related
to the economy and crime and shootings
right why do you never hear about the
black shootings uh because it's black on
black crime right so if it was white
people shooting black people you'd hear
about it if it's black people shooting
white people you won't hear about it if
it's black people black people you're
definitely not going to hear about it
Chicago right now because they're a
sanctuary City and they're already
struggling for the reasons we've just
laid out right Generations post welfare
state uh they're not too happy the black
residents of Chicago uh that they're
about to get 250 to 500 illegals uh
being busted into their neighborhoods as
we speak take a look
it's important is that we really
established that this is a humanitarian
crisis and we're here
South Shore residents responded with
resounding rejection
while this crisis May constitute an
emergency for the city of Chicago it
does not constitute an emergency for the
South Shore Community
incoming migrants have overwhelmed
District police stations by the hundreds
it's my turn it's my turn hello but city
leaders could barely eke out a word of
the details about a proposed Respite
Center at the former South Shore High
School when it comes to the total number
of people at South Shore at any given
point in time it is fluid we'd start
with 250 500.
did you do that without consulting us I
am concerned with safety in the area
do you see what the Democrats once again
are doing to black people so just to
reiterate until the 1970s after Decades
of slavery Generations Jim Crow et
cetera et cetera as Thomas all said it
wasn't until the early 70s the welfare
state the black family started crumbling
then once it started crumbling you get
drugs in there you get crime you get
people that are stuck in in the projects
over generation and generation because
they're being given things by the
government so that breaks your incentive
to get out and now you Flash Forward
another 50 years and what are the
Democrats doing to the residents of
Chicago in these black communities right
now the communities are already hurting
and now they're saying oh we're going to
toss all of these immigrants in there
these illegal immigrants and we're going
to give them stuff right and of course
that will come at your expense and it'll
bring more drugs into your community and
more crime and a whole bunch more now
what's also interesting about that is
imagine if it was just a different
racial component how the media would
have reacted that imagine if that had
been a bunch of white people in the
audience yelling that they don't want
illegals there everybody would be
calling them racist right they MSNBC
would be playing that clip CNN The View
everybody would be saying look at all
these white people they don't want those
brown people coming into their
neighborhoods in this case it's black
people that don't want the illegals
coming to their neighborhood so you're
not going to see that sort of thing uh
on MSNBC or CNN and I'm certainly not
blaming them for being racist they don't
want more illegal people who by
definition are breaking the law to come
to their communities uh it continued
here's some residents explaining why
they do not want these people there and
it is their god-given right not to have
them there because we're supposed to
have a border
these resources that have not come to us
now you want to overly compensate for
people who never lived here before and
they need to be taken care of first and
foremost before anything else happens
here yeah
why would any leader put our black
communities already riddled with crime
at further risk by placing unbetted
non-taxpayers steps away from our city
our seniors our children and our homes
we've worked so hard on our own to
secure
we are at War people
our communities are at War
they are violating our communities and
we asking that we have we across the
country we asking that we're demanding
for office of Black America or whatever
you want to call it to deal with issues
like this
uh I did get placed on the waitlist but
I was told that the immigrants were
taking priorities
see that's the story that a lot of
people don't know and it just it hurt me
I'm like oh wait a minute I understand
we need to be humanitarian but these
people are that my participant are third
and fourth generation Chicago born bred
fed and raised here
my grandmother May well the character
rest in peace always said Craig charity
starts the home first and then they go
abroad
okay again I just want to reiterate the
point imagine if any of the people that
you just heard there were white people
saying we don't want them in our
neighborhoods this is a war and
everything else everyone would be saying
they're racist now of course these
people are not racist right they want
Law and Order in their communities they
want their public officials to take care
of them before they take care of illegal
people so they're asking the they're
asking the very very Basics there's a
certain Beauty to all of this because a
whole bunch of these people are going to
be red pilled right now right because
these people probably voted for
Democrats because they thought oh
Democrats are giving us more stuff
that's generally how it works that's
what the Democrats have oh we will have
more stuff we'll take from some people
and give to us that's how it works with
the Democrats but now these people are
realizing oh the Democrats actually
don't care about us either they have to
find new constituencies and their new
constituencies will be these illegals
that eventually they will get to vote
for the Democratic party because they'll
give them the stuff while they're
screwing over you so what is the
justification for bussing in these
migrants and what's the justification
for basically not having a border where
well our Department of Homeland
secretary Alexander mayorkas the guy
should be I mean his eyebrows alone
should be in a science
experimented I don't know what's going
on there listen to his answer listen to
this ridiculously
um you might say racist you might say
racist answer on why we should bring
these people into the United States
what is the economic cost of your broken
immigration System since there are
businesses around this country that are
desperate for workers
there are desperate workers looking for
jobs in Desperate workers in foreign
countries that are looking for jobs in
the United States where they can earn
money lawfully and send much needed
remittances back home what is the cost
of a broken immigration system that is
the question that I am asked and that is
the question that I pose to Congress
because it is extraordinary oh it is
extraordinary because basically what
he's admitting there he's saying oh
there are people that want jobs in other
countries and our businesses here need
workers so yeah we're just letting
everybody in so first off he's in
complete dereliction of his duty now
this idea that somehow we need people to
take our jobs here now I get it there
are certain jobs that a whole bunch of
people don't want that absolutely is
true when we bring in migrant workers
and they're working in our fields and
all of those things it's not necessarily
the most fun job it's very it's physical
and it's tough and everything else but
we have an awful lot of unemployment
especially post covid we have an awful
lot of unemployment so wouldn't you
wouldn't a sane Society if we were in a
sane Society wouldn't we be encouraging
people to take jobs that are tough not
so that you have to be in the field
every day for the rest of your life but
hopefully with some chance to make a
little bit of money
keep that money within your family and
your community he's more interested
seemingly in having illegals come here
work those jobs and then send that money
the remittances back out of the country
it's so it's so incredible and the fact
that they are telling it to us they are
telling us uh right in front of our
faces and we are just kind of letting it
happen but this is why the members of
these communities are protesting
mayorkas and they're protesting their
own Democrat officials in places like
Chicago but they've done this Democrats
and big government officials have done
this forever right they have always
sacrificed American citizens for illegal
immigrants they've just always done it I
am for legal immigration and we can all
talk about what it would look like to
have a secure border and an honest
process to have people come into this
country if you're watching this most
likely unless your parents came on the
Mayflower uh your you know your
ancestors came on the Mayflower they
came in Legally probably through
Ellis Island like my great great
grandparents did and then they built a
better life for their kids but you can't
just let everybody Rampage through the
country to take jobs that a bunch of
people don't want ruin cities and then
send the money out it just doesn't work
here's a little more from Thomas Seoul
on just that
you're as dubious about the editorial
position of the Wall Street Journal
which is consistently pro-immigrant as
you are dubious of the president of the
United States because your point is
neither one of them really knows in
enough detail who these 11 million
people are whether they're doing net
good or harm to the economy so you
that's it you don't buy the Wall Street
Journal argument that on net surely
they're doing more good than harm more
economic good than harm you don't buy
that no and especially when they're
trying to talk about having people in
agriculture I mean this is the country
that has had a chronic surplus of
agricultural output for decades on in
clusting the taxpayers billions upon
billions of dollars but because the
federal government subsidizes this yeah
but the Surplus right yeah right right
yeah yes in fact I I I think the federal
government's subsidizes the water that
creates the Surplus that it then
subsidizes again
uh and I I think I think that that uh
any discussion of of people in the
abstract drives me crazy because there
are no abstract people
100 years ago people understood that and
so when there was a debate about
immigration there was a multi-volume set
of tomes about the characteristics of
the immigrants from various countries
where where do they how do they kids do
in school they have the guts to be picky
yes they said we'll take some yes but
they better do us good yes okay
you know it's funny what seoul's saying
right there at the end that's what uh
you would be construed or you would be
told you are racist if you say that now
what we're going to have some set of
rules related to who can come into the
country we're going to see where they're
from and what they believe and what
their cultural norms are and are they
involved in criminal activity and are
they pushing fentanyl through the border
and a whole bunch of other stuff will
they assimilate properly in the United
States that sounds like crazy right-wing
America first mega stuff
coming from one of our greatest
intellectual Minds in the in the last
probably Century but guys the question
remains so why are these illegal aliens
being bussed into our cities and
flooding our border right now like
basically what happened in the last two
weeks that now we are watching a
complete zombie invasion of the United
States uh well here's uh the Washington
examiner explaining what happened we had
title 42 expire on May 12th just a
couple days ago and here's what's going
on
it's the stroke of midnight on east
coast and it's official the title 42
policy that was brought on under
President Trump has now been canceled
under President Biden and what that
means is migrants now who cross the
border illegally will no longer be
immediately expelled back to Mexico back
to their home countries it's a huge
moment for the United States as 2.8
million people have been expelled back
to their countries under this policy it
opens up border patrol to a really
catastrophic situation should the more
than 10 000 people who have been
Crossing daily continue to come continue
to rise in numbers and place more of a
burden on processing centers the Biden
Administration is prioritizing quick
releases into the United States seeking
Asylum is not required and right now
we're bracing for a surge of Asylum
Seekers at the ports of Entry as well as
between those ports of Entry
guys I just can't be clear like the
Democrats are trying to destroy the
country and if you don't see it they're
trying to overrun the country title 42
was put in during covid so that we
couldn't we wouldn't have this Mass
immigration illegal immigration of all
of these people from all over the world
coming through our border and bringing
covet in so we if they tried they title
42 pushed them out real quick title 42
expires a couple of days ago and now all
of these people also knowing that listen
if you just have to be in another
country and see a video of mayorcas and
majorcus was like boy we do need more
people because people in America don't
want to do those jobs and we would like
people to do those jobs and you can send
your money back home and now all of
these people are rampaging through well
how many we've got some info from the
Washington Post illegal border crossings
have topped 10
000 per day this week the highest levels
ever and we've got a little bit more
from the U.S border Patrol total
encounters uh as you can see here 2017
about 310 thousand two thousand eighteen
four hundred thousand two thousand
nineteen eight hundred and sixty
thousand two hundred twenty four hundred
and five thousand so then it went down
right it goes down there because of
title forty two and covet and everything
else then it blows up in 21 1.6 million
22 2.2 million and 2023 as of today over
a million now I also want to connect
that to something else because you might
be watching and you might be going oh
but you know America we're big and we
can let everybody in and we're nice and
we're not racist the problem of course
is that what these people do some of
them are good people obviously but some
of them are not and that's actually not
the issue the issue is you either are a
nation-state and you have borders and
you say these are our citizens and these
are not and there's a process to become
a citizen if that's what the nation
wants uh and some Nations don't want it
and that's okay too you should decide
what you want in the nation that you
live in
um but we can either have a nation or
not the problem though is it's not just
good people come in and it's people that
are often bringing drugs and crime and a
whole bunch more here's some info on the
number of fentanyl deaths from 99 to
2021 in 99 to 2013 it was usually
between one and three thousand people
dying per year because of fentanyl 2017
it was 28 000 2019 it was thirty seven
thousand twenty twenty fifty six
thousand twenty Twenty One seventy
thousand and it is increasing now so
there is a connection between illegals
bringing drugs in and then the drugs
that are killing people on our streets
and if you don't want to take my word
for it might I recommend that you book a
ticket to San Francisco walk around
Market Street and then pray you don't
get killed so the the question here
really is does the left in America do
the Democrats see this as a problem and
the answer obviously is no right Biden
mayorkas Karin Jean-Pierre AOC they want
our borders open they also will tell you
that we are a racist country and a
patriarchal evil country apparently they
want everyone to share in the horrors
but they are more concerned about
something else right instead of being
concerned about the borders what are
they really concerned about these days
well you
you guessed it uh they are concerned
about white supremacy because they need
racial division as as a wedge basically
as a weapon to advance their political
agenda because I don't think it has any
support so you have to keep people
really really scared in this case of
white people uh here is majorcus once
again this guy it never stops with this
guy uh talking about violence in America
and you're not going to believe who he's
the most scared of
in the terrorism context domestic
violent extremism is our greatest threat
uh right now individuals are driven to
violence because of ideologies of hate
anti-government sentiments false
narratives personal Grievances and alike
and regrettably we have seen a rise in
white supremacy first off I want to be
very clear about one thing I have a lot
of anti-government sentiment I'm not a
terrorist and I am not calling to
overthrow the government but these
buffoons you should be resentful uh and
sort of angry at these people you can't
take the law into your own hands but it
is that guy's job to make sure we have a
border and he's actually making sure we
don't have a border he should I don't
know if it's impeached what do you do
with these people you like I don't even
know what the technical term is but the
guy should be given the boot I think
that would be the technical term anyway
it continues because it's not just
majorcus that's worried about these
white people and notice they never name
the white people can't we get a name of
a white like who's a white supremacist
these days you got your David Duke he's
the old go-to uh there's that frog kid
whatever his name is who else Dave Rubin
I mean there's a couple of them but I'm
saying it's not Peterson whatever
there's not a ton of them that's what
I'm saying anyway Joe Biden this is the
elderly man pretending to be president
he has dementia everyone knows it
they're throwing him up uh for 24 which
is absolutely completely ridiculous he
gave the commencement speech at Howard
University it is a historically black
college and uh stoked the racial Flames
enjoy
so stand up against the poison
of white supremacists I did my inaugural
address to a single out
as the most dangerous terrorist threat
to our homeland is white supremacy
[Applause]
[Music]
and I'm not saying this because I'm at a
black hpcu
I say Wherever I Go
oh shut up you old wind bag that's
exactly why you're saying it because
you're a pandering old buffoon and
what's funny is that line was obviously
not written on the speech right like
that's the part I'm not saying this
because I'm in a room with a whole bunch
of black people but screw Whitey yeah
okay yeah we love it we love it oh it's
just terrible
guys
the thing is it's not just the
government doing this this is the entire
machine doing it uh you may remember
that there was you know I didn't do much
news for the two weeks that I was away
but there was another mass shooting as
there often is in the United States in
these days and it's not the guns it's
because of mental health and drugs and
polarization and a whole bunch more but
let's set that aside for a moment there
was a mass shooting in Texas and I want
to show you a little bit about how the
media framed it this is from DC Drano uh
he's retweeting a Washington Post
article so here's what the Washington
Post says first the gunman who opened
fire on an outlet mall in Dallas suburb
Saturday killing at least eight people
was a man in his early 30s who may have
had white supremacist or Neo-Nazi
beliefs people familiar with the
investigation said Sunday now DC Drano
retweeted it and he said they're calling
the Texas shooter a white supremacist
because they don't want Americans to
know about violent drug cartels running
human trafficking trafficking operations
on our border which of course that's
ultimately what this had to do Ashley
Saint Claire also chimed in on this same
shooting the media tried to say that the
mass shooter in Texas was a Neo-Nazi
motivated by white supremacy nothing
screams white supremacist Neo-Nazi quite
like a Mexican gang name a Mexican gang
member named Mauricio Garcia so yes
unless you're telling me that Mauricio
Garcia the Mexican gang member was
actually a secret white supremacist and
that's why he did this he shot these
people in Dallas because in the name of
whiteness
you see the point they lie to us about
ever anything that they can do to keep
you upset about race to keep you upset
about bigotry you know perceived bigotry
and homophobia and transforming that's
what they do because if a whole bunch of
us lined up to them lined up together
against them and said you know this
ain't working anymore and we love this
country and there are some basic truths
that we all know that are self-evident
and we just don't need you people
anymore and we're not going to listen to
you as you try to destroy our
communities uh well they'd quickly be
out of a job and that would be a problem
for them so guys I think you get it in
essence by stoking this false racial
division amongst Americans they're doing
everything to not unify us right they're
going out of their way to not unify us
and if you couple that with their
actions on immigration we're losing the
America that we once knew right it is as
simple as that that when I talk about
this culture thing like if you believe
that America is fundamentally evil and
you want open borders and you want to
call everyone racist and all those
things then what does tie us together
and how long will we have in America
that was pretty damn good for 250 years
well Thomas Soul also has chimed in on
that if you let everybody in you might
change the makeup of America in ways
that may not be so great
uh it's not at all clear that if you
were to throw the borders wide open let
anyone come who wants to that this would
still be the same country 50 years from
now and so uh in a sense you can't let
everybody come to America because if
everybody came to America it wouldn't be
America anymore
if everyone came to America it wouldn't
be America anymore now is Thomas Soule a
white supremacist
uh is the black mother who we showed you
a few minutes ago who is upset that they
are bringing in illegal immigrants into
her neighborhood that are taking
resources away from her and her family
is she a white supremacist right but
that's literally what mayorkis and Joe
Biden would have you believe when people
stand up for their country and their
community and their family they are
labeled the white supremacist and the
cool thing about white supremacy these
days you don't even be have to be white
to be a white supremacist pretty good so
what do we do so how do we save America
well I think having some level of a
national identity some level of unity
through through the idea of nationalism
not white nationalism but nationalism
meaning pride in America pride in our
founding documents pride and freedom and
individual choice and all of those
things that would be good how about
tightening immigration tightening our
border and things of that that thing
things of that nature right how about
that that might be good and you might be
listening to this going but but
nationalism it sounds scary so what is
nationalism guys it's very easy to
describe I've done several shows on this
nationalism is where a nation so we are
a nation where we will take pride and
action in preserving and strengthening
our cultural and National Heritage and
ours in the United States you know
having just come back from Israel they
have a very obvious national identity
right it is mostly a Jewish country 80
Jewish country so you can there's a
there's a there's an obvious history and
and traditions and things that make
sense there then I went to Hungary
they're largely a Christian Nation and
they want to protect their borders and
their Heritage so it's obvious ours is a
little more complex because we are that
Melting Pot and that's what the left and
all the people into identity politics
that's what they're using against
they're using our strength that everyone
came here putting aside the prejudices
of the past everyone came here because
our streets were paved with gold because
there was a chance in America and you
could Sue happiness and we're so crazy
in America that we put it in our
founding documents pursue it we can't
guarantee it but you may as well try
when you're here and it largely has
absolutely worked so when you say
nationalism a certain set of people are
going to call you a racist and a bigot
and far right and everything else
um but the point is if you're a
nationalist country you will also take
care of your minorities which is why
there are 20 percent Christians and
Arabs in Israel and they have the exact
same voting rights as every Jew they're
hungry has the largest Jewish population
in in Europe right now as Jews are
fleeing France and fleeing the UK
because they've imported all sorts of
other people from Africa and the Middle
East who don't have Western values
they're exporting the Jewish people who
have been there these things are
happening right now they're a little
scary to talk about but they're
happening right now yoram hazoni who
I've had on the show he is the founder
of the national conservatism movement uh
he explains that there is virtue
actually in Defending Your borders and
Defending Your national identity here's
a little snippet
America will be able to move back
towards being a tolerant country when
there is an alternative that is
nationalist that is tolerant because
it's nationalist
and cares about
America
and cares that other nations should be
allowed to care about themselves and do
things their own way as well
I really hope I'm making the point clear
here guys if we care about America first
and I know that's a scary phrase again
to sub what he's saying there is hey if
America if you care about America you
care about your values your culture your
founding documents and all of those
things you'll find the spaces to be more
inclusive of people who think a little
bit differently right that's that's the
way you do it but we can't do it the way
that we're doing it right now which is
everyone come in and also we're really
flawed and we're horrible and we're
going to constantly be destroying our
economy while giving money to some
people and putting criminals in these
communities and all these things this
whole thing does not work so what yoram
is saying is we have to return to the
idea that this thing is good there is a
reason for the United States the same
way he's saying every nation should have
that right and I believe that as well
every nation on Earth if you are a
nation on planet Earth is pale blue dot
floating in the big vacuum if you are a
nation you have every right to defend
what whatever it is your nation agrees
upon as the cultural norms and that's
what we have to figure out you may have
heard of this Jordan Peterson guy he's
talked a bit about nationalism lately I
thought this was quite good
well nationalism is easier to understand
I think because
you need an identity
and it has to be Collective because
human beings live collectively it's the
fact that we share an identity that we
can all sit here in this room peacefully
because the identity is partly who you
think you are but it's also partly what
you expect from the world and from
others and because you have an identity
that's similar to you you can sit
together peacefully because you expect
and desire something and so do you and
it's the same thing and that's what it
means to have a shared culture you have
to defend that culture and it has to be
a sufficient let's say tightness or
magnitude so that it makes sense for you
to belong to it it's not so diverse and
chaotic that it means nothing and I
think that part of the reason why we're
seeing a return to nationalism is
because
the European identity is so amorphous
that people can't establish a
relationship with it and that's not a
good thing
[Music]
so much there
diverse and chaotic that it means
nothing doesn't that kind of feel like
what we are in right now they're
constantly telling us diversity is our
strength but diversity is not our
strength it can be a strength within a
system that makes sense but when
diversity for the sake of diversity it's
like progress for the sake of progress
no sometimes you progress to a point you
go boy we actually accomplished
something this is pretty good let's set
up shop we don't have to keep going
right
let's build a nation how about that
pretty fertile ground over here and we
fought all the bad ideas of the past
together you don't you don't just go and
go and go because eventually there's a
cliff and that's what the progressives
and the left and the Democrats I'm sorry
that's what they want to take us down to
so Europe for the most part is really
struggling with this right now they let
in all of these migrants all of these
illegal immigrants they did it out of
weird guilt right Germany has a huge
amount of guilt because of World War II
so they let in millions of people and
now their social systems are collapsing
they're having all sorts of cultural
divide uh just glue and look at the
videos of the streets of Paris with the
amount of Africans they've brought in
this is not about skin color it is about
culture and identity and values and if a
society will not protect those things
then you end up with that amorphous
nothingness this what do I always say
this slow descent to hell that's what
we're in right now because we we don't
have enough people that will just say no
more now I think we have it at some
State levels right I don't I'm not even
going to say
uh the state that I live in in this show
that starts with an F I'm not even going
to say it because I think I can do a
whole show without saying it but it is
there are places where it kind of works
where we're returning to Law and Order
and borders and and policies that make
sense and defense of community and
defensive parents who don't want their
children to be indoctrinated into things
and much more but now let's Loop this
back to the to the beginning with Oprah
and fatherhood
uh what it's not just nationalism that
will save us right it's not just the
idea that we will sort of all step up
together and build a country that's
going to make sense and defend those
things first what you need are good
people to do it right like it's a
bottom-up approach you need enough
people as Jordan would say to stand up
straight with their shoulders back you
might need a bunch of men to do it you
might need a bunch of strong fathers to
do it uh this image this goes around the
internet all the time I saw this one
from Tim Kennedy but I think it really
captures sort of what's going on here
Hard Times create strong men right when
when you're when you have to fight for
Freedom then you get strong men right to
hoist that flag in enemy territory
strong men then create Good Times boy
you can build skyscrapers you can build
extraordinary cities you can do
absolutely incredible things but then
Good Times create weak men right because
it starts getting so good you get fat on
the goodness you don't remember what you
were fighting in the first place and
then weak men create hard times you are
here right San Francisco is a great
example of this right it was so good
Silicon Valley it was so awesome and
then they just they became weak they
imported all of the idiotic ideas that
we should have let go and now as I said
earlier it is a nightmarish zombie
apocalypse there but let's also go back
to the beginning here's a little bit
more uh from Larry Elder sort of in
response to that to that Oprah piece
just about why
fathers and decent men in a society are
actually important
Tupac Shakur the late rapper once said I
know for a fact that had I had a father
I'd have some discipline I'd have more
confidence he admitted he began running
with gangs because he wanted the things
a father gives to a child especially to
a boy structure and protection
your mother cannot calm you down the way
a man cans jakur said you need a man to
teach you how to be a man
yeah I think you got it guys maybe I'm
feeling this a little bit more having
been on the road for two weeks and then
seeing my two kids and realizing just as
I've consistently realized over these
last eight months how important it is to
set up a world that will be strong for
them so they don't have to go through
the hard times what if what if they
could go through good times and still
become strong men like that would be
pretty good and I actually do think that
that's possible but the point is we need
strong men in society you just do you
just do little more from JP
it's okay to be a man it's not okay it's
necessary
what the hell are we going to do without
men you look around the city here you
see all these buildings go up these men
they're doing impossible things they're
under the streets working on the sewers
they're up on the power lines in the
storms and the rain they're keeping this
impossible infrastructure functioning
this thing that works and in miraculous
manner they work themselves
to death
and often literally the gratitude for
that is solar sorely lacking especially
among the people who should be most
grateful you see University professors
especially of the social justice bent
they take everything they have for
granted failing to understand entirely
that there's a massive infrastructure of
unbelievably hard-working
solidly laboring working-class men
breaking themselves in half on a regular
basis making sure that everything that
always breaks works I think something
just hit me I know we've played that
clip before but what I'm interested in
right now
is I think you know this I'm interested
in finding solutions to these problems
but what I'm interested in is finding
the good people who are going to be part
of that right it doesn't I'm not just
talking about political leaders but it's
you and your community if you're
coaching a baseball team or if you're
just the father who's willing to stand
up against the school board that's
indoctrinating your kids or anything
else like we all got to start finding
each other right I think that's what the
beauty of The Internet's been it's what
the good part of social media has been
that we've been able to find each other
and you know sure they can silence us
and they can take down posts and all of
those things but I think if we can find
enough serious people right now uh we
really can fix this whole thing and just
to go back to some of the unserious
people if you were to listen to Joe
Biden whose boogeyman scaring the hell
out of a bunch of people at a black
college you know and white supremacists
they're coming to get you and
everybody's like hey white supremacists
are coming to get us they're the
scariest it's insane or mayorkas like
mayorcas I don't know if he has kids but
what would majorcus do if what if
illegal immigrants showed up at his
house would he not let them in he'd have
to let them in I mean he's tolerant he's
diverse and everything else you know
what the better alternative would be it
would be work hard so you can live in a
good community and maybe you could build
a fence at your house I'm pretty sure
America's probably has a fence probably
locks his door at night so all of these
people
are complete Hypocrites and everything
else we must keep exposing them we must
keep finding the people that are
fighting properly and everything else
and that really is the point because
then the political stuff
will actually start making sense again
but right now we are in exactly what
Jordan described in the in the not the
last clip but the one before we are in
this just amorphous none of it makes
sense oh yes boys or girls and anyone
can come to our horribly racist country
and all of those things none of it makes
sense but I think enough enough of us at
this point have just had enough and
we're just gonna have to figure out how
to fix this thing and I just believe
that we can I just believe that we can
ladies and gentlemen if you have not
subscribed already please do it
rumble.com reubenreport if you'd like to
join us for a post game show uh you can
do that right now at
reubenreport.locals.com by the way I
should have mentioned it up top but
yesterday was a huge day for uh Rumble
we announced the acquisition of the
call-in app which is a really really
great way of doing live audio call-in
shows so that's something that I'm going
to be incorporating into our post game
show where I will take audio calls like
old school AM radio
uh and I that way instead of just
reading questions from you guys I can
actually have conversations with you
guys we'll do that for subscribers only
so we're going to be integrating the
call-in features into the locals app and
into Rumble which is really awesome uh
David sax who you guys know has been on
the show many times he was the founder
of Colin uh so with the acquisition he
is now on the board of Rumble he is an
incredible Fighter for free speech uh
also Rumble got the number one twitch
streamer in the world Kai senat he is
doing an exclusive show on Rumble I
don't know what's going on over there on
Twitch they're playing pole position or
something something like that right uh
but it's uh it's very cool good things
are happening over there the the
alternative pipes of the internet are
being built anyway hope you enjoy the
show I felt a little sharper today I
will continue to sharpen the knife
throughout the week uh we've got a cold
close for you and I'll see everybody
else in about 47 seconds
question of title 42 tonight the U.S
government is expecting what is being
called an unprecedented surge of
migrants at the southern border given
the conditions there right now would you
consider that a humanitarian crisis
absolutely
you know first thing you have to
understand is the United States country
based off immigrants
not allowing immigrants into our country
goes against what our founding fathers
stood for
you know it goes against the basic
guidelines of what the American dream is
I get a population control issue is a
big thing and not an influx risk of jobs
but most of these migrants immigrants
are going to go work in agricultural
Fields most people are not you and me do
you want to go out into a field and pick
fruits and vegetables probably not are
we going to
probably not so with that surge coming
in you know they're going to be coming
uh bus to cities like Washington DC to
Chicago to Philadelphia in Chicago this
week we've seen police stations are the
only places left for these migrants to
stay there's there has been suggestion
that citizens of these cities of Chicago
of Washington DC kind of allow and and
bring these migrants into their home is
that something you would be willing to
do
if I needed to yeah if someone if
someone approached me and said hey
I need a place to stay I would give them
I give him the shirt off my back getting
the shirt off your back so you would
also be willing then to give them
financial support you know we were at
Union Station uh when the migrants came
in and there were people offering
financial assistance giving them paying
for bus tickets to get to their
destination a lot of them have family in
the U.S that's something you would also
be willing to do absolutely shut off
your back yes thank you for your time
thanks
[Music]